notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Luc cardinas bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes mère
d'Alfortville porte-parole du Parti
socialiste et président de l'encas c'est
l'association qui représente les centres
communaux d'action sociale on va en
parler évidemment dans cette interviewé
d'abord on commence par la réforme des
retraites le carbonates 9e journée de
mobilisation hier à l'appel des
syndicats pour la première fois dans une
journée de mobilisation syndicale des
violences violences en marge des
cortèges dans plusieurs villes est-ce
que la contestation est en train
d'échapper au syndicat déjà il faut
condamner toutes ces violences et j'ai
vu hier que vous notamment la porte de
l'hôtel de ville de Bordeaux brûlée une
mairie c'est le premier guichet
républicain donc j'apporte tout mon
soutien à tous ces mers la mère de Paris
la mère de Nantes le maire de Bordeaux
qui ont vu ces exactions arrivées après
le discours du président de la
République n'a pas été très apaisant
dans son interview de 13h
il comprend pas les Français il comprend
pas les Français et ça aurait torique de
dire mais j'ai été élu pour faire cette
réforme déjà ils m'ont parce qu'il sait
très bien lui qui a été si vide de
sondage que pendant sa propre compagne
Harry s'interactif a fait un sondage sur
les items qu'il proposait le seul qui
ressortait comme négatif aux yeux de
l'opinion publique c'était les retraites
donc il s'est pertinemment qu'il y avait
un front du refus sur ses retraites et
aujourd'hui on est passé d'une crise
sociale à désormais une crise politique
majeure et institutionnelle le seul
moyen quand on est président de la
République de se sortir d'une crise
institutionnelle c'est soit de dire
dissolution et on retourne vers le
peuple pour voir ce qu'il souhaite comme
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale soit
c'est de dire référendum est-ce que vous
êtes pour ce projet que je vous ai
présenté puisqu'il est si sûr de lui or
il a donné une fin de non-recevoir et
d'ailleurs il n'a pas été extrêmement
élégant de manière républicaine
vis-à-vis de Gérard Larcher le président
du Sénat puisque il invite à déjeuner le
mardi mais il laisse fuiter la veille au
soir avec les parlementaires ce qu'il
comptait faire de manière
institutionnelle vous voyez c'est ça le
mode de faire des manuel Macron c'est
toujours laisser entendre qu'il écoute
mais en fait il dirige seul et ça
commence à se voir ça se voit dans son
gouvernement ou c'est un peu sauf qui
peut sauf qu'il veut on l'a pas
je demande que le Président de la
République comprenne l'instant dans
lequel nous sommes
un remaniement une dissolution pour vous
c'est
au présent de la République moi je veux
que l'on retourne aux urnes je souhaite
que le peuple est à nouveau le
référendum
moi je demande l'un ou l'autre
référendum ou dissolution mais ça peut
pas durer comme ça ça ne peut pas durer
comme ça et je pense qu'il est grand
temps que Elisabeth borne qui est en
sursis si on a bien compris hein parce
que son est déjà élargissement de
majorité se finira par des cartons et
elle partira malheureusement parce que
c'est impossible et donc ils sont au
pied d'un mur alors soit ils comprennent
ce que dit ce que disent donc
compatriote soit on va continuer comme
cela et je ne vois pas où est le bout du
tunnel et on a vu je le disais cette
violence vous en avez parlé vous les
avez condamnés est-ce que malgré tout
vous encouragez à poursuivre la
mobilisation les syndicats ont annoncé
une nouvelle journée de mobilisation
mardi est-ce que pour vous il faut
continuer
il y a une intercy syndicale qui
organise le mouvement social le Parti
socialiste accompagne ce mouvement
social il y a une nouvelle journée mardi
prochain qui est annoncée et bien nous
serons à nouveau dans cette dixième
journée aux côtés des syndicats et aux
côtés des Français qui manifestent vous
ne redoutez pas ce qui se passer dans
ces journées on sent qu'on a
l'impression que la violence monte d'un
cran est-ce que ça vous inquiète moi
j'appelle à la responsabilité du
Président et du gouvernement si on veut
que les choses se calment il faut que
encore une fois il redonne la main au
peuple Fabien Roussel il appelle les
Français à bloqué l'outil de travail
est-ce que c'est aussi un appel que vous
lancez non je dis à nos compatriotes en
à mes conscience qu'ils doivent choisir
ce qu'ils veulent faire on peut pas
quand on est un responsable politique
envoyer des injonctions pour dire nos
concitoyens ce qu'ils doivent faire
chacun est responsable il y a des grèves
des blocages des risques de pénurie de
kérosène en Île-de-France il y a eu des
réquisitions cette nuit à la raffinerie
de Gonfreville est-ce que pour vous
c'est réquisitions sont justifiées
c'est en tous les cas le choix du
gouvernement je pense que c'est vous
comprenez non c'est un choix qui durcit
encore un peu plus le ton et je pense
qu'il faut dans ce temps présent arrêter
d'être brutal tout ce que l'on voit
depuis plusieurs semaines maintenant et
plusieurs mois c'est de la brutalité
institutionnelle brutalité vis-à-vis des
corps intermédiaires et des syndicats
désormais brutalité contre nos
concitoyens donc moi je pense qu'il faut
que tout ça s'arrête encore une fois une
radicalisation de ce mouvement est-ce
que ce mouvement est en train de changer
de visage selon vous
c'est évident qu'il est en train de
prendre encore plus d'importance on l'a
vu hier il y a c'est une des plus
grosses mobilisations que l'on a eu on
ne joue qu'il y ait malheureusement des
débordements en marche des
manifestations ça a toujours existé il
faut que maintenant la préfecture de
police de Paris lorsqu'elle va définir
le cortège de mardi prochain que l'on
prenne les enseignements d'hier au soir
et que le cortège soit bien balisé en
termes de mobilier urbain de poubelles
etc de ne pas laisser de prise à ces
quelques-uns qui voudraient justement
le propos de Monsieur Darmanin dans ces
cas-là si on jette des anathèmes moi
j'ai parlé d'une politique de droite
extrême donc au regard de je ne sais pas
soyez je me mets dans dans le même
comportement que lui il suffit pas de de
stigmatiser les uns et les autres comme
des responsables politiques sont des
partis politiques de gouvernement donc
demandé à Monsieur Darmanin ce qu'est
l'extrême gauche chez lui comme moi je
lui demande ce qu'est au regard de ce
qui se passe la droite extrême désormais
ça veut dire quoi c'est à dire vous il y
a un problème de quoi de maintien de
l'ordre il y a un problème dans la
politique de Gérald Darmanin qu'est-ce
que vous voulez je pense que les
instructions qui sont données par le
ministère de l'Intérieur sont des
instructions d'extrême grande fermeté on
a l'impression de revenir autant de
Charles Pasqua voilà mon sentiment donc
trois en tous les cas il faut mesurer
vous lui demandez de changer de
politique je lui demande de faire
attention à nos concitoyens qui défilent
dans les instructions qui sont données à
nos policiers que je soutiens parce que
nous policiers sont aux ordres de leur
hiérarchie qui sont données contre les
citoyens qui les manifestent je pense
qu'il y a des instructions qui sont
données à nos policiers pour être
extrêmement ferme voire trop ferme
il y a des violences aussi envers les
élus envers les mers envers les
parlementaires
une personne est un incarcéré dans une
dans un asile reconnu comme tel et qui
me menaçait de mort
vous appelez est-ce que c'est violent
soit plus sévèrement condamnés
moi j'appelle juste qu'on applique la
loi voilà moi vous savez je suis un
maire lorsqu'il y a à mon encontre des
propos qui sont homophobes normalement
c'est un délit les parquets classes je
me porte ici ville pour faire appliquer
la loi et faire condamner la personne il
y a un problème de moyens dans la
justice donc je suis pas de donner
encore plus d'outils législatif pour
durcir le ton et je crois qu'il y a tous
les éléments pour le faire mais là aussi
les parquets ou les procureurs la
justice en général manque de moyens
sévère pour faire appliquer la loi et
protéger nos concitoyens et les élus
sont des concitoyens comme les autres
avec cela de différents qui sont en
première ligne et c'est ce que vous
disiez les maires avec évidemment bien
sûr l'association des merdes de France
nous avions fait un livre blanc sur
toutes les problématiques contre les
élus la ce sont des maires de France à
toutes les associations d'élus c'est un
sujet mais c'est aussi le symbole d'une
forme de de délitement et de perte de
repères de notre société
on attaque les journalistes on attaque
les médecins on attaque les pompiers
quand ils vont éteindre des feux de
poubelles on attaque tous les repères et
les symboles de la République et je
pense que notre société a besoin encore
une fois d'apaisement et j'en reviens au
début de propos il faut que le Président
de la République rassemble les Français
il a été élu pour cela mais vous pensez
vraiment qu'Emmanuel Macron va retirer
son texte vous l'avez entendu encore
mercredi il insiste sur la nécessité de
faire cette réforme des retraites ça ne
fait pas plaisir mais elle est
nécessaire il a dit vous pensez vraiment
qu'il va le retirer je crois qu'il leur
tuera pas non voilà je pense que
maintenant la balle est dans le camp du
Conseil constitutionnel ça veut dire que
pour vous le combat politique au Parti
socialiste est perdu non on va continuer
le combat politique à l'occasion des
prochaines échéances qu'elle soit
d'abord sénatoriales puis européenne sur
cette réforme on n'a même pas eu le
temps de dire ce qu'on voulait dire au
Parlement puisqu'on s'est arrêté à
l'article 2 sur 20 articles donc le
Conseil national voilà le conseil le
Conseil constitutionnel oui enfin sur
une mesure un mini 49-3 en accélérant
les débats donc tout a été fait pour que
finalement on bride la parole politique
donc désormais j'imagine que les sages
du Conseil constitutionnel vont regarder
ça sur le droit c'est la faute de la
gauche c'est la faute de la France
insoumise si on n'est pas allé jusqu'au
bout du débat ils ont tout fait pour
empêcher le débat à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est pas votre nom de dire
ils ont tout fait d'empêcher le débat
qui ont déjà la règle du jeu c'est
d'imposer 50 heures de débat donc à
l'Assemblée nationale donc un débat très
contraint quand on voit que cette maison
quel Sénat que j'ai toujours considéré
comme la maison la plus sérieuse des
deux chambres ayant été sénateurs et
députés je peux un peu comparer et je le
redis ici à votre antenne parce que le
Sénat montre depuis maintenant le début
de son quinquennat tout son rôle et
toute son importance même dans cette
belle maison où généralement les débats
sont des débats politiques de fond le
gouvernement a appuyé sur le champignon
pour l'empêcher donc on voit bien qu'il
y a un 75 heures de débat on voit bien
il y a un malaise sur ce sur ce sur ce
texte quand on va toucher à la vie des
gens et que le président et son
gouvernement disent circuler à il y a
rien à voir bah je comprends qu'il y a
un malaise chez les syndicats et dans la
rue
c'est une crise vous le dites qui va
au-delà de la réforme des retraites et
on l'entend dans la rue la colère
maintenant elle va au-delà du simple de
la simple contestation de cette réforme
Emmanuel Macron il veut mettre la
question du travail sur la tablette que
pour vous c'est une bonne chose
qu'est-ce que vous attendez de cette loi
travail qui doit arriver d'ici l'été bah
déjà je me demande dans quel contexte il
va pouvoir discuter avec les syndicats
au regard de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
donc il faut de la confiance pour parler
de la loi travail il faut moi ce que
j'ai la confiance entre syndical je
pense je ne parle pas pour les syndicats
mais de ce que j'écoute des uns et des
autres de Laurent Berger ou de Monsieur
Martinez je n'ai pas un sentiment qu'on
s'est confiance actuellement mais la loi
travail doit poser les conditions de la
rémunération des salaires de
l'augmentation des salaires d'arrêter
cette politique de 6 ans il y a un
problème je sors un chèque énergie je
sors un chèque alimentaire je sors un
chèque un chèque un chèque un chèque et
finalement
tout ça c'est du saupoudrage si on veut
que les choses aillent bien dans ce pays
il faut qu'une bonne fois pour toutes il
y ait une vraie un vrai volontarisme
d'augmentation des salaires et pas
seulement se glosser comme l'a fait le
président de la République au trésor en
disant jamais les smicards bonjour le
terme très péjoratifs ont été autant
augmenté voilà si vous voyez la
conception qu'a le président de ses
concitoyens et dans cette interview il a
également évoqué il a également parlé du
RSA il va aller chercher les
bénéficiaires du RSA les aider à revenir
vers l'emploi les responsabilités car
certains dit-il ne travaillent plus
parfois depuis des années ou des
dizaines d'années
en disant c'est normal qu'ils aient pas
envie de travailler parce qu'avec la
covid ils se sont habitués à plus
travailler dans les franchement c'est le
ton d'un président de la République
aujourd'hui le RSA vous le savez il y a
une dix départements qui se sont portés
volontaires de toute couleur politique
ils sont volontaires c'est le temps
d'une expérimentation
généralement quand on donne une
expérimentation c'est qu'on se donne le
temps du recul de regarder comment
quels sont les résultats et de voir si
on généralise ou pas or je vous parle
d'une expérimentation dans 10
départements et quand on écoute le
président de la République on l'est déjà
dans la généralisation donc c'est
toujours la même méthode c'est je fais
ce que je veux en fait et sigmatiser les
personnes qui ont des minima sociaux
par rapport à la problématique du plein
emploi alors qu'ils sont les plus
éloignés de l'emploi il y a quelque
chose qui ne colle pas et le parent
pauvre aujourd'hui aussi du politique
gouvernementales c'est l'accompagnement
social suffit pas de dire droit et de
voir mais et encore moins moi ça me gêne
politiquement voir ça me choque que de
dire que le RSA qui est un minima social
doit être adossé à du travail à des
heures de travail c'est un minima social
voilà mais on attendra ce que donne le
résultat d'expérimentation justement
vous présidez l'incas union nationale
des centres communaux d'action sociale
vous tenez votre congrès
[Musique]
dans le baromètre social que je rendrai
publique mardi matin un Français sur
cinq déclare avoir franchi la porte d'un
CCAS aujourd'hui nous avons des
publiques nouveaux des retraités des
actifs des jeunes qui nous demandent de
l'aide de l'aide alimentaire notamment
et au regard de de nos moyens financiers
parce que nos budgets sont contraint les
CCAS vit des dotations que les
collectivités leur verse à l'occasion du
vote du budget moi-même cette année je
veux augmenter de 10% le budget de mon
CCAS 2,6 millions d'euros ça ça vous
donne le niveau d'investissement
lors de votre concret j'ai plusieurs
messages à faire passer au gouvernement
déjà ce gouvernement ne prépare pas la
société du Bien vieillir en 2040 vous et
moi nous aurons un pays où un Français
sur deux aura plus de 65 ans que fait-on
pour réparer cette société avec la
question de l'autonomie aujourd'hui une
grande loi dépendance à l'été par
Emmanuel
elle n'a pas eu lieu elle n'a pas eu
lieu c'est pour ça que Lucas avait versé
au Congrès des mers en 2021 un livre
blanc avec des propositions notamment
sur la revalorisation des 26000 aides à
domicile du public qui avait été oublié
du Ségur nous avons rencontré le 25
janvier dernier à l'occasion de nos vœux
nous avons fait préalablement une
réunion avec le bureau d'une casse
Jean-Christophe combe le ministre des
Solidarités malheureusement au regard de
l'échange que nous avons eu il n'y aura
pas de grandes lois encore du grand âge
et l'autonomie donc l'une casse va
travailler à faire des propositions
parce qu'il faut que l'on avance et il
faut aussi que l'on avance sur un sujet
qui m'est extrêmement cher ce sont les
outre-mer j'ai fait des Outre-mer une
priorité et quand je reviens de
Guadeloupe et que je vois que
l'illettrisme est un des premiers une
des premières priorités de de des élus
parce que les élèves en Guadeloupe par
exemple perdent chaque année 20% de leur
temps scolaire à cause des Sargasses des
cyclones il y a pas d'eau potable dans
les écoles qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour ces
territoires
départements français voilà donc une
casse nous sommes des la plus vieille
association de mer après la session des
mères de France et nous sommes là pour
apporter des propositions politiques et
je crois qu'il en aura pas mal à Bourges
pendant 3 jours que vous ferez passer la
semaine prochaine on parle du Parti
socialiste il y a des législatives du
dimanche en arrière je les ai partielles
mais qui ont une résonance nationale
parce que elle divise la gauche elle
divise votre partie Olivier force ou
bien la candidate la France insoumise
nuque qui est la députée sortante
Nicolas Mayer Rossignol lui soutient la
dissidente socialiste ça veut dire que
le Congrès de Marseille n'a pas résorbé
les fractures au sein du PS en tous les
cas moi je regrette que l'accord de
Marseille ne soit pas respecté et le
Conseil national
à la majorité investi madame taurine
pourrait être la candidate de la nupesse
moi je regrette le comportement de mes
amis de l'Ariège et de l'Occitanie c'est
leur choix politique je le respecte mais
je dis à tous ceux qui sont contre la
nups à François Hollande à Bernard
Cazeneuve à Carole Delga à Hélène
Geoffroy Stéphane Le Foll tous ont été
au gouvernement et au plus haute
fonction de l'état qui se trompe de
chemin politique la nupes c'est l'union
de toute la gauche la nuit Pesse a donné
une espérance et je l'ai vu dans ma vie
Alfortville au moment où nous avons fait
ce choix et Olivier fort et le courage
de se mettre autour de la table pour
dire construsion une coalition des
causes communes c'est ça la nupes et
quand j'entends une autre petite musique
je leur dis très bien et donc aux
prochaines échéances puisque vous êtes
contre l'union de la gauche vous partez
avec qui sont contre l'union de la
gauche ils disent qu'ils sont contre
cette union parce que le Parti
socialiste s'efface derrière la France
insoumise vous savez il faut pas refaire
l'histoire de ce qui s'est passé en juin
dernier en juin dernier normalement nous
avions fait des échanges avec le Parti
communiste et les écologistes pour faire
des alliances législatives Jean-Luc
Mélenchon fait 22% à la présidentielle
nous nous connaissons les résultats que
nous avons fait et nos partenaires
traditionnels nous ont dit avec une
table sur l'épaule vous êtes gentil les
amis mais nous on va d'abord aller voir
la France insoumise et c'est ça qu'il y
a de d'extrêmement
incohérent c'est que on ne rappelle pas
cela et on était dans un corner les
socialistes on voulait quoi qu'il y ait
un ou deux députés la présidente de
région d'Occitanie a amené des
candidatures pensant qu'elles étaient
les meilleures elles ont tout été
balayées ou en juin dernier par
d'autres candidats qui étaient ceux de
la nuit passe donc on a vu à l'épreuve
des urnes ce résultat donc moi
c'est entêtement on verra ce qui se
passe dimanche prochain mais j'en
appelle à la responsabilité là aussi de
mes camarades et de se mettre autour
d'une table avec nous et de construire
un programme de gauche commençons en
France sanitaire vous savez quand vous
reprenez les livres d'histoire
franchement entre François Mitterrand et
Georges Marchais c'était autrement plus
dur que ce à quoi on assiste aujourd'hui
d'une table mais sans vous selon le
Journal du dimanche il y a eu un dîner
cette semaine entre François Hollande
Bernard Cazeneuve et Nicolas manière qui
est premier secrétaire de vie est qu'en
pensez-vous j'espère qu'ils ont eu de
joyeuses agapes voilà donc je les laisse
encore une fois dans leur choix
politique
il peut rester première secrétaire
délégué dans ces conditions
c'est à lui de nous le dire aujourd'hui
aucun de ses amis de son courant
n'est dans la direction nationale un
pied dedans un pied dehors ça me fait
penser un peu du et en même temps on a
bien vu que ça fonctionne pas donc qui a
deux maisons Perla raison donc Nicolas
devra faire des choix donc est-ce que
clairement vous lui dites il faut
quitter il faut qu'ils aucune vous
m'entendrez jamais avoir des injonctions
vis-à-vis de camarade moi je connais
Nicolas
vous êtes pas dans un parti socialiste
où vous voulez à tout prix rester
ensemble sauf que vous n'arrivez plus à
cohabiter c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai
on cohabite ensemble on va le démontrer
au sénatorial on fait on fait pas
qu'ensemble après on n'est pas d'accord
sur la ligne politique sur la oui mais
elle a été tranchée
elle a été tranchée on peut pas refaire
le match quand il a été tranché dans le
cadre d'un congrès c'est quoi c'est
définir une ligne stratégique politique
elle a été définie c'est celle d'Olivier
Ford
républicain Éric Ciotti a à demi
Aurélien Pradier de son poste de numéro
2 parce qu'il suivait pas sa ligne
est-ce qu'Olivier Ford doit démettre
Nicolas Mayer Rossignol parce qu'il ne
sait pas Céline
et pas le modèle politique d'Olivier
Faure et on n'a pas tout à fait on n'a
pas tout à fait
il faut l'apaisement là aussi je sais
que notre premier secrétaire fait le job
et nous autour de lui aussi voilà égale
à Ariège ce sera un épichénomène moi je
pense que la candidate de la nupesse
sera première au premier tour elle avait
quand même 4700 voix d'avance sur la
candidate des copains socialistes de
l'Ariège en juin dernier donc je
comprends même pas pourquoi ils
remettent une pièce dans la machine pour
démontrer que la stratégie est encore
une fois mauvaise parce que je pense
c'est ça la démonstration qui aura lieu
dans les cieux dimanche prochain et on
suivra bien sûr tout ça merci Lucas
merci merci d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin